JULIE JAMES: Hey, everybody,
it's great to be here with you.
As you've already
heard, I am Julie James.
I host Broadway Names with
Julie James, no relation,
on Sirius XM radio featuring
show tunes and celebrity
and news and all those great
things about Broadway coast
to coast 24/7.
I'm delighted to be taking
the next hour, or maybe two,
if George speaks in his
signature slow rate,
to introduce you to
a piece of theater
that I've been obsessed
with since its world
premiere at the Old Globe
Theater in San Diego.
A show whose imminent
Broadway arrival
I've been anticipating since
I first heard the music,
and we're going to
hear a full five songs
showcased here today with
very special guests, including
the world premiere of one of
the new numbers from the show.
"Allegiance" is a
new American musical
based on true events, which
means, of course, that I can't
go any further without
introducing our guest of honor.
He's a sci-fi icon, a tireless
advocate for human rights,
and the star of "Allegiance,"
a man who really needs
no introduction
because you're already
friends with him on Facebook.
That's right, here he is, the
one and only George Takei.
[APPLAUSE]
Welcome, welcome, George.
GEORGE TAKEI: Thank
you very much.
JULIE JAMES: This is
going to be great.
So let's dive right in.
One thing that people may
not know about "Allegiance"
is that it's inspired by your
very childhood and your years
while imprisoned during the
Japanese American internment,
and that you yourself
were an internee.
GEORGE TAKEI: Yes,
that is correct.
JULIE JAMES: It's unbelievable.
So tell us a little
bit more about that.
GEORGE TAKEI: Well, Japan bombed
Pearl Harbor, as you know,
on December 7, 1941 and that
plunged the whole world it
into another world war.
For Japanese Americans, American
citizens of Japanese ancestry,
it was a catastrophic
experience.
Because overnight,
we were looked
at with suspicion and fear
and outright hatred simply
because we happened to
look like the people that
bombed Pearl Harbor.
And the hysteria grew and grew
until on February 19, 1942,
the President of
the United States,
Franklin Delano Roosevelt,
ordered all Japanese Americans
on the West Coast,
approximately 120,000
of us, to be summarily
rounded up, with no charges,
with no trial, with no due
process, the central pillar
of our justice
system, and ordered
them to be incarcerated in
10 barbed wire prison camps,
in some of the most god
awful places in this country.
The blistering hot
desert of Arizona,
the sultry swamps of Arkansas,
southeastern Arkansas,
the cold windswept high plains
of Wyoming, Idaho, Utah,
Colorado, and two of the most
desolate places in California.
On April 20, I celebrated my
fifth birthday and my parents
tell me that they gave
me a birthday party,
but I don't remember that.
Because a few weeks after that
my parents got me, my brother,
a year younger, and my baby
sister, not yet a year old,
they got us up very early,
and they hurriedly dressed us.
And my brother and I were in
the living room looking out
the front window, and we
saw two soldiers marching up
our driveway.
They carried rifles
with bayonets
shining on top of them.
They stomped up the front porch
and banged on the front door.
My father answered it and
literally at gunpoint,
we were ordered out of our home.
My father gave my brother and
me little pieces of luggage
to carry, and we went
out on the driveway
and waited for our
mother to come out.
She took some time.
And when she finally
emerged she had our baby
sister in one arm
and a huge duffel bag
in the other and tears were
streaming down both her cheeks.
I may have been five years
old, but I will never
forget that terrifying morning.
We were taken from our
home on a truck where
there were other Japanese
American families gathered
to Santa Anita racetrack,
a nearby racetrack,
and driven to the stable
area where we were unloaded.
And we were herded over
to the stable area.
And we were told by the soldiers
that this one horse stall would
be where we would
stay temporarily
while the camps are being built.
All five of us, three
children and our parents,
moved from a two bedroom home
on Garnet Street in Los Angeles
to this smelly horse stall.
For my parents, it was a
degrading, humiliating, painful
experience, but for
five-year-old me
I thought it was
kind of fun that we
get to sleep where
the horseys sleep.
If you breathe deeply,
you can smell them.
So we were there
for a few months
and then the construction
of the camps was completed,
and we were put on trains
with armed soldiers
at both ends of each car,
as if we were criminals.
And we were transported 2/3
of the way across the country
to the swamps of
southeastern Arkansas.
I still remember the barbed
wire fences that confined me.
The tall sentry towers with
the machine guns pointed at us.
I remember the searchlight
that followed me
when I made the night
runs to the latrine.
But young children are
amazingly adaptable.
What would be grotesquely
abnormal in normal times
became my normality behind
those barbed wire fences.
It became normal for me
to the line up three times
a day to eat lousy food
in a noisy mess hall.
It became routine for me
to go to a mass shower
with my father.
And it became normal for me
to go to school in a black tar
paper barrack and
begin the school
day with the Pledge of
Allegiance to the flag.
I could see the barbed wire
fence and the sentry tower
right outside my
schoolhouse window
as I recited the words with
liberty and justice for all.
JULIE JAMES: Incredible.
It's such an incredible
thing that you're
going to be telling
this true life
story, a mostly unknown
story of America,
and events that
you lived through,
but that you're going
to be reenacting
these events on
a Broadway stage.
What does that mean to you?
GEORGE TAKEI: It's a very
meaningful experience for me,
very exciting for me,
but it is profoundly
meaningful to Japanese
American families
and to the Japanese
American community.
And like all musicals there is
the story of forbidden love.
And it's an epic story of
the World War II battles.
We tell the story of a heroic,
most decorated military unit
in the entire Second
World War, which
happened to be made up of
all Japanese Americans,
the 442nd Regimental
Combat Team.
But most of all, it's
a story of two people.
A brother, I play Sammy,
and Sammy's sister,
played by Lea Salonga, and it's
their story, their adventures.
It's a story that
you've never heard,
but a family that you
will never forget.
JULIE JAMES: Beautiful.
Beautifully said.
So you know words
are powerful, and we
have a lot of great
plays on Broadway.
Why did you think
that a musical would
be the best way
to tell the story
of "Allegiance"
and your history?
GEORGE TAKEI: Words have the
power of reaching the brain,
set us thinking.
Music reaches the
heart, our feelings,
and when you combine the
two together in a musical
it becomes a singular force.
It is a beautiful
story that we tell,
and that story is still too
little known in this country.
And so I've spent most of my
adult life talking about it
to universities, to
governmental agencies,
and to corporate groups.
And we've developed
a musical about it,
and this is what's
so exciting to me.
And I consider this
musical my legacy project,
and my husband, Brad,
shares with me this passion
to get our legacy
project on Broadway.
JULIE JAMES: Oh,
that's so sweet.
Is Brad here?
Hi, Brad.
Everybody, Brad Takei.
It's so great to see
you here and the fact
that he's by your side
and believing in you 100%
and helping shepherd
this is fantastic.
It's so great to see you, Brad.
So now, in the show
"Allegiance," you play,
not one, but two
characters, right?
GEORGE TAKEI: That's correct.
In the San Diego production
at the Old Globe,
I had the pleasure of the
sharing the role of Sam Kimura
with a very talented
young man, Telly Leung.
JULIE JAMES: I love Telly.
GEORGE TAKEI: Oh, yeah,
he's a fantastic performer.
And Telly plays
Sam as a young man
during the period
of the internment.
And I play Sam in the
present, many years later.
But I also play Sam's
grandfather, an immigrant man
who came to this country
with hope and ambition.
And he's something of a rascal.
JULIE JAMES: Typcasting?
Typecasting, I hear?
Telly is, of course, a
veteran of the Broadway stage.
You might have seen him
in "Wicked," or "Rent,"
or "Godspell."
Many fans will recognize
him from "Glee,"
and unfortunately, Telly, like
some of our other original cast
members, was not able
to be here today,
but we are lucky enough to
have some behind the scenes
footage of Telly
recording an upcoming
single from the score
of "Allegiance,"
and it's called
"What Makes a Man."
[VIDEO PLAYBACK]
[MUSIC - "WHAT MAKES A MAN"]
[END VIDEO PLAYBACK]
[APPLAUSE]
JULIE JAMES: I got
the chills everywhere.
Oh my gosh.
That was fantastic.
Telly Leung in that video.
You know, "Allegiance"
isn't actually though
the story of just one man.
It's about a lot more.
GEORGE TAKEI: No, it isn't.
It's about our family
and the community,
and ultimately,
it's about America,
because it was our Constitution
that was egregiously violated.
But, primarily, the
story is about Sam Kimura
and his sister, Kay Kimura.
And that sister is played by
the luminous Lea Salonga, a Tony
Award winner for her
starring role in "Miss
Saigon," and the voice
of Jasmine in "Alladin,"
and also the voice of Mulan
in the Disney animated film.
And she is spectacular.
It's a story that
people have never heard,
but it's a family
you will not forget.
JULIE JAMES: I think one of
the other things I'm really
struck by in the show is the
strength and determination
of the women in "Allegiance."
One of the songs
that comes to mind
is called "Stronger
Than Before,"
and it's a duet sung between
the two main female characters.
And, like a lot of women
during World War II,
the characters have
both been empowered
by the fight for
freedom and found
strength in two
surprising places,
the support of an
unexpected ally
and also from within themselves.
Here to sing the world
premiere-- this is really
special everybody, of
"Stronger Than Before"
are two Broadway treasures.
We have "Wicked's" Lindsay
Mendez and "Godspell's"
Anna Maria Perez de Tagle
singing a special pop
arrangement by Lynn Shankle.
Welcome, ladies.
[APPLAUSE]
[MUSIC - "STRONGER THAN BEFORE"]
JULIE JAMES: Two of my
favorite Broadway voices.
They are fantastic.
GEORGE TAKEI: And if you know
the context of that song,
it is so moving.
It comes near the end.
JULIE JAMES: Yeah.
GEORGE TAKEI: And
it is powerful.
JULIE JAMES: Yeah.
Brings back some memories of
some Kristin and Idina for me.
So George, one of
the main, I guess,
central pieces of the
plot of "Allegiance"
focuses on the
loyalty questionnaire.
Can you tell us more about that?
GEORGE TAKEI: The
loyalty questionnaire
turned all 10
camps into turmoil.
This was a year
into imprisonment,
and the government realized
that there is a wartime manpower
shortage and here are
all these young people
that we labeled
enemy non-aliens.
Non-aliens.
What does that mean?
That's a citizen
defined in the negative.
They even took the word
citizen away from us
and put us in
these prison camps.
How do we tap them?
Their solution was a
outrageous solution, a loyalty
questionnaire, which was
a series of questions.
But there are two key questions
that everyone in the camp
had to respond to.
Everyone over 17 years of age,
from 17 to 87, man or woman,
American born or an immigrant.
Question 27, one of the two
controversial questions,
asked will you
bear arms to defend
the United States of America?
This being asked of a
17-year-old young man
or an 87-year-old
immigrant lady.
It was preposterous.
Question 28 was one
sentence, and it
was a very insidious sentence
with two opposite ideas.
It asked will you swear
your loyalty to the United
States of America and
forswear your loyalty
to the emperor of Japan?
We're Americans.
For the government to assume
that we're born with a loyalty
to the emperor, that
there's something genetic
about a loyalty to the
emperor, was outrageous.
You can't forswear something
that you don't have.
So my father said, they took my
business, they took our home,
they took our
freedom, the one thing
I'm not going to give
them is my dignity.
I am not going to grovel
before this government.
He answered no, and for that
he was labeled disloyal.
There was another group
of young men who said,
I will fight for my country
because I'm an American,
but I will fight as an American.
If I can report to my hometown
draft board with my family
back home, I will
fight for this country,
but I will not go
as an internee going
from behind these barbed wire
fences, leaving my family
and loved ones behind.
And for that courageous,
principled stand
they were tried for draft
evasion, found guilty,
and thrown into
federal penitentiaries.
But there's another
amazing group of people.
These young men bit the
bullet, and women too, they
bit the bullet,
swallowed their pride
and answered both questions as
the government wanted them to,
and they went from behind
these barbed wire fences,
putting on the same uniform
as that of the sentries that
guarded over us,
leaving their family
and loved ones in imprisonment
to fight for this country.
And their story is
an amazing story.
They fought with incredible
courage and valor.
They sustained the
highest combat casualty
rate of any unit of
it's comparable size,
and they came back the
single most decorated unit
of the entire war.
They were welcomed back
to the United States
on the White House lawn
by President Truman, who
said to them, you fought not
only the enemy, but prejudice,
and you won.
JULIE JAMES: That's incredible.
You know, I think one of the
things that really strikes me
about this story, your
story, is that throughout all
of this, at the
same time, you're
keeping up some
sense of normalcy.
It's just absolutely incredible.
Tell us a little bit about that.
GEORGE TAKEI: Well, it's
my parents actually.
JULIE JAMES: Yeah?
GEORGE TAKEI: And all
the adults that did it.
Yes, we tried to have normalcy
while living in those black tar
paper barracks.
My mother's scavenged
around and got
the military to give her
some scrap military fabric,
and she made curtains
for our barrack windows
so that we'd have some privacy.
There are some who
had green thumbs,
and they took that
barren landscape
and turned it into bountiful,
productive victory gardens,
if you will.
And there are others who
were handy with crafts,
and they worked on crafts.
My father loved
baseball and he was
a member of our
block baseball team.
And I remember going to
sleep at the end of the day,
my mother put us to bed
early because we were kids,
hearing the songs of the
1940s, because the camp command
occasionally, about every other
month, allowed the young people
to have dances in the
mess hall after dinner.
They cleared the tables
and the benches away
and played their
dance songs, or they
may have performed themselves.
And I went to bed
listening to the big band
sound of Tommy Dorsey, or The
Andrews Sisters, the swing
sound, or the bebop sounds.
And so that's one
of the fond memories
of my childhood
in a prison camp.
JULIE JAMES: Yeah.
That's astounding.
We're going to use some
of that as inspiration
for the next song that
we're going to hear,
is kind of just such a
sort of a dance tune.
The song "Paradise,"
I understand,
parodies both the
injustice of the internment
and the propaganda
surrounding it.
But it's a toe-tapping
number, kind
of the likes of which you
can only see on Broadway.
So here to perform "Paradise,"
from the cast of "If/Then,"
is Mark de la Cruz.
Welcome.
[APPLAUSE]
[MUSIC - "PARADISE"]
JULIE JAMES: Thank
you, Mark and the cast.
Oh, I love that.
That is so Broadway.
GEORGE TAKEI: Isn't
that terrific?
JULIE JAMES: Love it.
So George, anyone who hears
you speak, or knows you
from online, knows
your body of work,
knows that you always
just shoot for the stars.
You have so much optimism
and faith in humankind.
You've been a catalyst for
social justice and innovation.
I mean, you're unbelievable.
You always ask us to
be our highest selves
and to better ourselves,
even if it's grammar online.
Thank you for that.
GEORGE TAKEI: Keep it coming.
Keep it coming.
I love it.
JULIE JAMES: So, I guess, what
I really want you to speak to is
how is it possible that
a man like you, who
spent your childhood as
a political prisoner,
can have all of this
unending optimism
and resounding
faith in humankind?
GEORGE TAKEI: Well, I think I'm
basically an optimistic guy.
I had parents that
were optimists.
I think it's optimism
that gets things done.
You know, we can do it.
I can do a marathon, 26.2 miles.
People say that's impossible,
but you say to yourself,
I will do it.
And even when your
muscles complain.
You say, muscle, you will do
it, and you wind up doing it.
And that attitude is in
my grandfather character,
Ojii-San.
He has a wonderful
line that I love.
He says-- and he's an
immigrant from Japan,
you see, flower bloom
where it is planted.
So even in those
harsh circumstances,
desolate high plains, or
the swamps, or the deserts,
you try to be the
best of yourself.
JULIE JAMES: That's
so inspiring.
I think that
determination is really
at the heart of
"Allegiance," and it's also
at the heart of the next song
that we're going to present.
You probably will
recognize our next guest
from a little tiny show
called "American Idol,"
and she is going to
be singing "Higher."
Here is the fantastic
Melinda Doolittle.
[APPLAUSE]
[MUSIC - "HIGHER"]
JULIE JAMES: Melinda Doolittle,
another of our special guests
here today.
GEORGE TAKEI: She
is sensational.
JULIE JAMES: Sensational.
GEORGE TAKEI: And the
song, in context, you
won't believe how moving it is.
JULIE JAMES: Wow, wow.
So I know many of
your fans are dying
to know, George, including
me, when is "Allegiance"
coming to Broadway?
GEORGE TAKEI: Ah, yes.
Well, as you know,
there are many,
many plays lined up
waiting to get a vacancy
and every theater on
Broadway is occupied.
JULIE JAMES: Spoken for, right.
GEORGE TAKEI: Yes.
Well, I'm a farmer's grandson.
My grandfather was a farmer
in the Sacramento Delta
and when a farmer feels
something in his bones,
that's pretty reliable.
And I feel in my bones that we
will be on Broadway in 2015.
2015.
So those of you who have already
bought your Priority Access
pass, or are on our
email list, or follow me
on Facebook, gaman.
That's a word you
know now, gaman.
JULIE JAMES: Yes, yes,
you've introduced it to us.
GEORGE TAKEI: We will be
on Broadway very soon.
JULIE JAMES: Excellent.
I'm so glad to hear that.
I'm going to go back
to gaman in a moment,
but also, I know
that you actually
have a very special surprise
in store for everybody today.
GEORGE TAKEI: Ah, yes.
We've made the
"Allegiance" mini album
completely free to
download on Google Play.
JULIE JAMES: Woo.
GEORGE TAKEI: You
can get it all free.
It features six songs
from "Allegiance,"
and this is our way
of saying thank you
to you for the support
you've given us on our trek
to Broadway.
JULIE JAMES: Trek.
Oh my.
GEORGE TAKEI: Oh my.
[LAUGHTER]
JULIE JAMES: That's fantastic.
I love all of the cool ideas
that you guys have come up
with like the priority
access and all that.
It's just fantastic.
So going back to
gaman, For anybody
who doesn't know, since you've
introduced me to that word,
but for anybody who's watching,
or here in our audience that
doesn't know, can you tell
us exactly what that means?
GEORGE TAKEI: Yes, gaman
means to endure with dignity,
to overcome whatever
challenges you
are facing, by
confidence and fortitude.
And it's a word that, you
know, I heard from my mother
often in camp.
I remember, particularly when we
we're lined up at the latrine,
and there I was, you know,
wiggling and doing a jig
to try to contain
myself, and my mother
would say, gaman, George, gaman.
And I gritted my teeth,
and I'm proud to tell you
I always made it to the
latrine with dignity.
But it's that word gaman
that made it possible
for us to make it through
that horrible period
behind those barbed
wire fences, gaman.
It's what kept it possible
for us to love each other
and to love this country
that we were born in.
JULIE JAMES: A story
of perseverance.
It's perfect.
Gaman is a wonderful
note for us to end
our little special
showcase here today.
So here to perform "Gaman"
from the score of "Allegiance"
is a spectacular group
of Broadway performers.
Come on and welcome
them to the stage.
[APPLAUSE]
[MUSIC - "GAMAN"]
JULIE JAMES: So this
is really exciting.
We're going to actually spend
a couple of minutes doing Q&A,
and I want to invite
anyone who has a question.
We're going to be inviting the
creative team of "Allegiance"
to join us on stage with George,
and if you have a question,
we have microphones on the right
and left side of the house.
And so we would
just ask you to step
right up if you have a
question, and then we also
have George's legion of
internet fans, I know,
have been furiously submitting
their questions as well.
So we're going to try
to take some of those.
So let me just have a quick
intro from our creative team
so you know who you are
being joined by here today.
It's great to see you guys.
What a great presentation.
LORENZO THIONE:
I'm Lorenzo Thione
and I'm the co-book writer
and producer of "Allegiance."
JAY KUO: Jay Kuo.
I'm the composer and
lyricist of the show.
MARC ACITO: I'm Marc Acito,
I'm the co-book writer.
LYNNE SHANKEL:
I'm Lynne Shankel,
I'm the music supervisor,
arranger, orchestrator.
STAFFORD ARIMA: Stafford
Arima, the director.
-Gosh, what a great,
great showcase today that
you gave us, just a brief
taste of "Allegiance."
It's just fantastic.
MARC ACITO: We won't disagree.
JULIE JAMES: So I would
love to dig right in.
Do we have anyone
that has a question?
I think you do.
I see someone here
in the audience.
AUDIENCE: I was just curious,
when are tickets going on sale?
JULIE JAMES: Woo.
LORENZO THIONE:
I'll take that one
JULIE JAMES: We like that one.
LORENZO THIONE: So
like George said,
we've been waiting
for a theater,
and we hope something will
happen for us very soon,
but we did come up and
George talked about it,
we did come up with an
interesting idea for getting
people who were
interested in the show
and were following
its development
and were eager to buy
tickets to go online, even
today, and buy what we call the
Priority Access Pass for $5.
You actually get
to be first in line
to buy tickets to
the Broadway show
before the tickets go on sale
to the general public, which
is an interesting way
to sort of make sure
that you have your pick to
whatever performance you want.
You know, before anybody else
gets access to the tickets,
you get your ability
to buy a ticket.
And if you then come
to the show you also
get a free download of the full
cast album, not the mini album.
So it's definitely
a great value,
and it's a great way for
us to know that there's
a real audience out there
waiting for the show to happen.
GEORGE TAKEI: And I might
add, for those of you who
have friends and
relatives out of town who
are going to be
coming to New York
to see "Allegiance," it is
particularly a good idea
to get a Priority Access
Pass, because you're not
going to be here
for a long time.
It's a limited period of time.
And so you can have your
dibs on a pair of tickets
before they go on
sale to the public
and be assured that those
few days that they're
going to be in town they
have a pair of tickets
to see the greatest show they're
going to see on Broadway,
"Allegiance."
JULIE JAMES: Well said.
Do we have any other--
GEORGE TAKEI: I'm
a television actor.
I'm used to doing commercials.
[LAUGHTER]
JULIE JAMES: Yes, your question?
AUDIENCE: Hi there.
I want to thank you
guys for coming.
I love to ask Broadway
performers when
they come a bit about
their experience,
putting their own personality
into the show and ad libbing,
but I think it's a
great opportunity we
have some of the
behind the scenes group
here that makes it happens.
So I'd love to hear
from your perspective ad
libbing, adapting the
show after it's written,
is that something you
encourage, you have a part in?
Is that solely up to the actors?
I'd love to hear
your take on that.
STAFFORD ARIMA: Oh I think that
once a show has been written
and we have a group
of authors who
have created dialogue and
lyrics and specific words
to say that the hope
is that the actor will
remain kind of on book.
Meaning, will say the words
that have been written as is.
I think that the element of
something feeling spontaneous
on stage, which is why a
lot of audience members
enjoy the live theater
performances because it does
feel alive and spontaneous, that
comes from an actor's bringing
to the material a kind of
reality of that moment.
If a performer
perhaps kind of zones
into just kind of
like doing it by rote,
then the performance
might feel stale.
But you know 99% of performers,
when they're in a show stay
kind of alive with the
material, but still
have the kind of context
of this is the words
that I have to say, this is
the blocking that I have to do.
Because in theater, you
know, lights are created,
spotlights are created,
there are specific areas
of the stage that the
actor needs to go to.
So if the actor decided
one day, oh, I just
want to walk around the stage
and not follow what was given,
then he or she might be
out of the light and all
of that kind of stuff.
So I think, in
essence, spontaneity
and an honest performance
will come from an aliveness,
but still within the
context of the material.
MARC ACITO: The performers
make it their own.
I think that's what
the audience senses
when it feels spontaneous.
We watched Melinda
Doolittle today,
and that's the first time
I've heard her sing that song.
And, you know, hearing it
in context of the show,
it feels like it's one thing,
and it's part of this story
that we've already
been telling you,
but what it pointed
out to me was just
how universal that story is.
How it felt like it was
Melinda Doolittle's story.
I'm thinking about, oh,
I didn't know she had,
you know, a swing when she
was a kid, Melinda Doolittle.
And we wrote it, but it felt--
they make it so their own,
you feel as if it's
them speaking to you.
And with Melinda, I'd follow
her anywhere, you know.
AUDIENCE: Thank you.
JULIE JAMES: Great question.
Great answers, everybody.
We have some questions.
We have a question
here in the audience.
We also have some from online.
So if you guys can
refresh my screen,
I think we have
some questions that
are coming in from
our online fan base.
But what's your question
here in the audience today?
AUDIENCE: Hi, this
is for George.
I was curious how
much you had to do
with the writing versus
just providing the story.
Like did you provide dialogue?
GEORGE TAKEI: No.
We have some gifted
writers here.
It actually began in
a Broadway theater.
Brad and I went to
see-- well, actually it
began in an off Broadway
theater, forbidden Broadway.
And there were two guys
seated in front of us.
They happen to be
Lorenzo and Jay, who
I didn't know from Adam, but
they recognized my voice,
and they turned around and
we chatted a little bit.
I guess I have a
recognizable voice.
And we saw that they
were theater lovers.
And that evening Brad and I went
back to our apartment saying,
yeah, it's wonderful to have
chatted with those guys.
The next night we went
to see "In the Heights,"
the Puerto Rican family
in Washington Heights,
and we walked into
the theater and there
were those two same guys
seated in the theater.
JAY KUO: They thought that
we were stalking them.
GEORGE TAKEI: And our
seats were in the same row.
We did think you
were stalking us.
JAY KUO: At some
point during Act One,
there's a song called
"Inutil," which means useless.
GEORGE TAKEI: Inutil.
Your Spanish
pronunciation is terrible.
JAY KUO: And I
looked over and I saw
George crying during that song,
so during the intermission
I asked him what had moved
him so much during that song,
and he started telling me about
how the notion of uselessness
really resonated with him
because his father felt
so useless trying to
protect and preserve
their family while they
were in the internment
camps of Arkansas.
And every hair on
my body stood on end
because I was hearing for
the first time this story
and realizing this
is a terrific story.
And I just turned
to Lorenzo and I
said are you thinking
what I'm thinking.
And we said--
LORENZO THIONE: It's like a
quintessential American epic.
Just the type of struggle
that these people had
to endure for a country that
many had come and sought
after as a promised
land, was just
something that we
thought was a story that
would resonate with
audiences everywhere.
JAY KUO: And so just
a few weeks later, we
had sent sort of a review of it.
LORENZO THIONE: Jay works fast.
GEORGE TAKEI: Yeah,
a few weeks later I
got a song on my computer,
and I listened to it,
and I was bawling at
my computer again.
And so I invited them to come to
the Japanese American National
Museum, which we
founded in Los Angeles.
It's an affiliate
of the Smithsonian,
and introduced them to the
details of the internment
experience.
JULIE JAMES: That's
so fascinating.
MARC ACITO: On top
of that, though, I'd
like to add that the
story, of course,
is inspired by
George's true story,
and the creation
of the characters
were really inspired
by him as well.
When I came on to
the project George
was playing Sam, which
is a very serious part,
and there's the chance for
him to play some high drama,
but there wasn't any place
for him to play comedy.
And I said, this
sci-fi legend has now
become an internet
comedy legend and I said,
you've got to give this
guy something to do.
So we invented the
role of Ojii-San
for him to be able to
have that other side.
And it really speaks to
what inspired me most
about the story,
is the absolute--
the intrepid quality that the
Japanese American people had
and the way they kept
their sense of humor
and the way in
which they blossomed
where they were planted.
They grew so much
in their gardens
that they actually had a surplus
that they supplied the war
department in a place
that nobody ever
thought anything would grow.
They bloomed where
they were planted.
It's a daily inspiration to us.
I mean, truly you
have to own gaman.
If the subway goes
away, and you're like,
oh, I have a terrible life.
You're like no one's putting
me in a camp, gaman, you know?
JULIE JAMES: Perfectly said.
We have a great question
from The G-dog in Fremont.
Got to love that screen name.
Having seen the
show in San Diego,
I'm curious what
changes are being
made for the eventual
Broadway version?
Good question.
MARC ACITO: A lot.
STAFFORD ARIMA: Do you
want to speak to that?
MARC ACITO: I think it
has become more refined.
The show runs the gamut
in terms of its bandwidth
of it's-- it'd be so easy
for this to be considered
a tragedy.
But at the same time, it's the
triumph of the human spirit.
So finding that full
range and the balance
between those
things where we can
take the audience to despair
and then uplift them has been,
I think, a real focus.
JAY KUO: We've worked
on a lot of new music.
And Lynne-- it's a real
pleasure to work with Lynne,
arranging some of the
new songs and working
that up together, especially
for this presentation.
LYNNE SHANKEL: Yes.
What the two ladies sang
today, "Stronger than Before,"
was an arrangement that I made
specifically for this event.
Like it's a lot poppier than
it is in the show itself,
and we just kind
of wanted to show
a different side of things.
Along with what Jay
was saying, just
to really show that these
themes really are universal.
That it's not just a show
about Asians for Asians.
That these themes are universal.
I mean, I can relate
to all of the songs
that we've sung today.
But we have a lot of
exciting new material.
Been working on a new
opening number, the number
that you heard today,
and a couple more,
and I'm so excited to
get back to work on it.
LORENZO THIONE: I just want
to add just one thing, which
is even San Diego came sort of
midway through a development
process that had taken years,
and the process has continued.
One thing that we've
been pleasantly
surprised at the
fact that no matter
how much the show had
changed, no matter
how many new scenes, no matter
how many new numbers, no matter
how many songs we would cut,
and there are more songs
cut than there are in the
show, and then put back,
it always felt
like the same show.
It always felt like the
story we we're telling
and the journey we were
bringing the audience with us on
was the same one.
And that sort of
reinforced in us
the idea that we
were making progress
towards the right goal.
JULIE JAMES: Really good.
How are we doing on time?
Do we have time for another
question from the online fans?
MALE SPEAKER: One more.
JULIE JAMES: All
right, one more.
This is a good one from
JNN 38364 up in Ontario.
Uncle George, which I
love that she calls you
that, you have been through
so much in your life,
was it difficult to play
a role in the production
without getting overly
emotional, or was the show
and sharing the story
more therapeutic?
GEORGE TAKEI: Well, she's
my niece calling in.
You know, the characters--
JULIE JAMES: Wait, you
said I was your niece.
GEORGE TAKEI: I have a
lot of nieces, believe me.
JULIE JAMES: And nephews.
GEORGE TAKEI: Blond haired
ones, red haired ones,
freckled face nieces.
This play is so specific and,
as was said, so universal.
The characters are so rich and
so human and to be one of them,
in this story, it
tears me apart.
And I am reliving that
and, yes, it's a catharsis.
I have a final
scene there as Sam
that is an opportunity
for me to feel everything
that I've felt as an
adult and let it hang out.
It's a wonderful, wonderful,
personal as well as
professional experience.
JULIE JAMES: And I love that
you said it was your legacy
and that just is
so, so touching.
And we cannot wait to get
more news for "Allegiance"
to come to Broadway,
in your words, 2015.
Let's put the good joujou
out there everybody.
I want to remind everyone
that on your way out
today there is an "Allegiance"
CD for you to pick up.
And, of course, as
George told everybody
that's watching online, it's
available for free today
on Google Play.
So don't miss your chance to get
that great six songs for free.
Especially, "Gaman,"
as we've all
said, we all need some gaman.
And I really want to thank
our incredible performers
and special guests who
were here joining us today
and our creative team.
You did such a fantastic job.
Of course, the one and
only, George Takei.
Thank you all for being here.
I'm Julie James.
Thank you so much.
[APPLAUSE]
[MUSIC PLAYING]